misery misery misery that's what you've
chosen I offered you friendship and you
spat in my face
[Music]
you spun your last web spider-man have
you not been so selfish your little
girlfriend's death would have been quick
and painless but now that you've really
pissed me off I'm gonna finish her nice
[Music]
damn Jay and I we're gonna have a hell
of a time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr. Osborn Peter thank God for you you
killed those people on that balcony the
government killed I had nothing to do
with it don't don't let him take me
again
protect me you tried to kill and man you
tried to kill Mary Jane what about you I
tried to stop it
I couldn't stop it I would never hurt
you
I knew from the beginning if anything
never happened to me it was you that I
could count on you Peter Parker would
save me and so you have thank God for
you give me your hand believe in me as I
believed in you I've been like a father
to you
be Assunta me
[Music]
I have a father his name was Ben Parker
Godspeed spider-man
[Music]
[Music]
either
don't tell Harry
you
you